as for the preps heading into Sunday's
big show the red carpets out stars are
already partying from Leo to Pacino a
list nominees packed a special dinner in
LA last night
welcome to the one-millionth Academy
Award this year there's no host again
but here's what we're expecting funny
presenter moments like last year cuz
Maya Rudolph's back hey chadwick boseman
what kind of plans you got later
plenty more comedic presenters will be
cracking us up from cording to Chris
Rock - we just got to work out what
we're doing yeah these two new co-stars
if they can get it together I just want
to pick out a dress I know you gotta get
on that faster but it's not quite the
result that you wore last night 9 time
Oscar host Billy Crystal joked with
2-time Oscar emcee Jimmy Kimmel about
the Academy's decision to go host lists
again you'd think that a host is
important to the show yeah seems like it
speaking of Crystal Palace frosty
crystals it's like over a thousand LED
video pals the new stage will be lit
this year especially with performers
Billy Eilish Elton John Janelle Monae
idina menzel and Cynthia Reeve oh you're
gonna perform so are you ready no I
think I am is more than a dream come
true at this point like it's beyond me
Chrissy max will also sing an
oscar-nominated song no pressure
[Music]
Brad and Leah are gonna be in the front
row and I will be staring them down
honestly all I do is think okay they put
their pants on the same way I do and I
have luckily met a lot of incredible
people so I'm like okay we are just
human yes
after the show's over the winners will
head upstairs to the Governor's Ball
that's where they get their Oscar
engraved and finally get to eat after
that three-hour show the menus courtesy
of Wolfgang Puck we're gonna talk about
1,600 people we also have small plates
so think it's almost like a tapas
restaurant except we make 25,000 plates
altogether we have over 200 chefs in the
kitchen so everything is made to order
just like in the restaurant we have
become extra prepared so we decided to
do 1,500 bottles of champagne which is
over 8,500 glasses even if you don't
walk away with the gold statuette
nominees won't be leaving empty-handed
an independent company not the Oscars
will hand out 24 swag bags one less than
usual this year were only giving 24 cuz
Scarlett Johansson was greedy and got
nominated twice inside celebs will find
over 65 gifts including a seventy eight
thousand dollar all-inclusive cruise and
some gifts are specifically matched to
celebs but we have these gold hollow-tip
date pins that I think leo is definitely
going to enjoy using and Brad Pitt
pretty famously announced that he was on
tinder so we think Brad might need to
upgrade his game so we've hooked him up
with a really cool $20,000 matchmaking
service
[Music]
you